THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
TELLS --
TO PREPARE AS A POLITICAL BRACE
SPREADS INTO THE CAPITAL OF
KAMPALA.
ALMOST THREE WEEKS, AGO THE
UGANDAN PRESIDENT DECLARED A
LOCKDOWN INTO DISTRICTS,
INCLUDING THIS ONE.
HERE YOU SEE THE UGANDAN HEALTH
MINISTER VISITING ANNA BULLOCK
TREATMENT UNIT.
YOU CAN SEE HERE HOW CASES AND
DEATHS HAVE BEEN RISING SINCE
THE OUTBREAK BEGAN IN
SEPTEMBER.
HEALTH MINISTER REPORTS AT
LEAST 49 PEOPLE HAVE DIED.
THERE BEEN 131 CONFIRMED CASES,
17 OF THOSE IN KAMPALA.
JOINING ME NOW IS UGANDA'S
MINISTER OF INFORMATION FORMER
HEALTH MINISTER CHRIS --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO SPEAK WITH US HERE,
MINISTER.
LET ME BEGIN WITH THE TWEET
THAT I SAW THE LAST 30 MINUTES
OR SO FROM THE PRESIDENT OF
UGANDA.
IF YOU CAN BRING UP THE TWEET I
JUST WANT TO READ IT OUT TO OUR
VIEWERS REGARDING THE EBOLA
SITUATION FIRST OF ALL THERE
WILL BE NO LOCKDOWN AND
THEREFORE PEOPLE SHOULD GO
AHEAD AND CONCENTRATE ON THEIR
WORK WITHOUT WORRY.
HOWEVER, WE SHOULD BE MORE
VIGILANT AND OBSERVE THE
S.O.P.'S PUT IN PLACE TO
CONTROL THE EBOLA SPREAD.
CAN YOU CLARIFY FOR US MINISTER
WHETHER HE IS REFERRING HERE TO
KAMPALA ONLY?
>> YES.
WE ANNOUNCED THE --
IN THE TWO DISTRICTS IS ABOUT
200 --
WEST OF KAMPALA AND THERE HAVE
BEEN FEARS AMONG THE RESIDENTS
OF KAMPALA WHEN WE ANNOUNCED
THE LOCKDOWN.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT WINS THERE
WILL BE NO --
IN KAMPALA ALL THERE ARE FAMILY
CASES AND THE CONTACTS HAVE
BEEN PUT UNDER QUARANTINE.
WE HAVE THE STRENGTH AND THE
SURVEILLANCE AND --
SO KAMALA WILL NOT BE PUT DOWN
OR MIX COMMUNICATED WITH.
>> SO THERE WILL BE NO LOCKDOWN
IN KAMPALA AND YOU JUST TOLD ME
THAT THOSE CONFIRMED CASES IN
KAMPALA WILL NOT 18 NOT 17.
IS THAT CORRECT, MINISTER?
>> IT IS EIGHT TEEN BUT WITH
ALL THE CONTACTS HAVE BEEN
QUARANTINED.
SOME EVEN COMPLETED IN 21 DAYS
SO THERE IS NO CAUSE FOR --
--
>> WHAT ABOUT THE TWO JUST SO
YOU MENTIONED I THINK WE HAD A
MAP BEFORE THAT IS COMMENDED
AND COME PENA.
THOSE WERE LOST.
DOWN OTHER IS GOING TO BE
LIFTED EITHER TODAY OR TOMORROW?
IS THAT STILL EXPECTED TO BE
LIFTED TOMORROW?
>> YES, THE DAYS AND TOMORROW.
WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT WE
EXTEND --
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND MAKE
ACCOMMODATION AS --
TO EXTEND THE LOCAL BALLOT.
ESPECIALLY IN CASSANDRA IT IS
TO ANNOUNCE AFTER --
>> SO YOU ARE RECOMMENDING THAT
THAT BE EXTENDED IN JUVENTUS
AND CASSANDRA.
JUST TALK TO US ABOUT HOW
WORRYING THE SITUATION IS IN
THE REGION ON FOR.
>> IT IS NOT WORRYING.
THE EPICENTER IS IN THOSE TWO
DISTRICTS OF --
AND WE WILL BE ABLE TO CONTROL
THE AND.
HAVE A ONE CASE OR TWO CASES OR
SOME FEW OTHER DISTRICTS.
THAT SITUATION HAS BEEN PUT
UNDER CONTROL AND WE HAVE A
STRONG TEAMS OF THE WORLD AND
ANOTHER SURVEILLANCE THAT WE
ARE PRESSING IN THE CONTACTS.
AND THE SITUATION HAS BEEN OUT
OF CONTROL.
IT IS NOT A CAUSE FOR WORRY.
AND WE HOPE --
WILL BE ABLE TO DECLARABLE OVER.
>> NO CAUSE FOR WORRY BUT YOU
ARE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LOCKDOWN BE EXTENDED.
ON THOSE PEOPLE WORKING ON THE
GROUND, WHERE IS THE MINISTER
OF INFECTED HEALTH CARE WORKERS?
>> YES WE HAVE SOME WORKERS AND
SINCE THEN WE HAVE STRENGTH AND
THE PROTECTION AND WE HAVE
INCENTIVES AND IT IS NOT A VERY
BIG PROBLEM BECAUSE WE HAVE
OTHER PPE'S WITH WORKERS AND
PERMANENT --
AND NOT AT THE MOMENT.
>> LARGE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE OUTBREAK BUT FOR MY
UNDERSTANDING IN MY NOTES SIX
HEALTH CARE WORKERS HAVE DIED.
IS THAT CORRECT, MINISTER?
>> YES WE KNOW AT THE BEGINNING
WHEN HIS WORK ENDED THERE
WASN'T A BULLET PROBLEM AND
THERE WERE SITUATIONS WHICH
WERE OPERATED WITHOUT
PROTECTIONS.
SO THOSE WHO DIED OF THOSE WHO
HANDLED THE EBOLA CASES WHICH
WERE CONFIRMED OUTBREAK.
SINCE THEN THERE HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN TERMS OF
--
>> SO WE ARE STILL AT SIX
HEALTH CARE WORKERS WHO HAVE
DIED FROM WHAT YOU ARE TELLING
ME, MINISTER.
JUST EXPLAIN TO OUR VIEWERS,
MINISTER, AROUND THE WORLD, WHY
THIS OUTBREAK IN PARTICULAR HAS
PROVED MORE DIFFICULT TO DEAL
COMPARED TO RECENT EPIDEMICS?
>> WELL FIRST OF ALL YOU KNOW
THERE ARE STREAMS OF --
AND WE ALSO HAVE WE ARE MORE
EXCITED WITH ABOUT SUSTAINABLE.
AND THE --
WE HAVE NOTED THE FIRST INDEX
CASE BECAUSE WE HAVE NO --
TROUBLING FROM WHERE AN
EPIDEMIC IS.
WE SUSPECT IT COULD HAVE COME
FROM THE COMMUNITIES WITHIN --
AND I THINK WE ARE CONTROLLING
IT BECAUSE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
WORSE THAN WHERE WE ARE.
BUT WE SEE WE CONFIRMED ONE
CASE AND THERE ARE MANY
RECOVERIES AND CASES THAT HAVE
BEEN RECOVERED FOR 3% SO IT IS
NOT ALARMING AND YOU HAVE A
ROBOT AND SYSTEM ON THE GROUND
WHICH IS HARDLY A --
SITUATION.
>> LAST WEEK I THINK WE HEARD
THERE WERE GOING TO BE THREE
VACCINES YOU CAN CORRECT ME IF
I AM WRONG THERE.
WHAT STATES ARE WE WITH THOSE?
>> YES, AS YOU KNOW THERE ARE
VACCINES WHICH HAVE BEEN
TRIUMPH THERE FOR US AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE RICH ARE
CITING ANOTHER --
WE RECEIVED SEVERAL VACCINES
WHICH WE ARE TRYING NOW IN THE
POPULATION HERE IN UGANDA AMONG
THE ADDITIONAL EFFORTS THAT --
HAVE RUN OUT OF IT.
>> YOU HAVE ALREADY STARTED
THESE?
>> YES.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
STARTING.
>> UNDERSTOOD.
MINISTER PLEASE KEEP US POSTED.
WISHING YO